dans cette école primaire comme ailleurs
au québec c'était jour de rentrée et
après trois semaines à la maison dont
une semaine d'école à distance
les élèves sont bien contents de revenir
en classe je t'ai quand nous de faire
l'école à la maison puis je voulais
revoir mes amis et en même temps je peux
nerveuse parce que ça fait longtemps
qu'on est parvenu en fait si jusqu'en
milieu dé nouvelles règles puis ça me
rend un peu nerveux
les parents eux sont pour la plupart
sous logique que les élèves reviennent à
l'école je suis très heureuse à 20h peu
inquiète mais j'essaye de rester le plus
optimiste possible quand jusqu'à présent
nous prouver que les buts fonctionner
relativement bien fait je pense que dans
un bus de retour éventuel à la vie
normale c'était la bonne chose à faire
retour en classe aussi pour marie-eve
les autres professeurs et la direction
de l'école pour qui les nouvelles
mesures sanitaires dont le port du
masque pour les plus petits vont poser
des défis communs quatrième année ça va
être nouveau pour eux de manipuler le
masque de le mettre dans les arts
commune tout ça donc ça va être vraiment
le de porter attention à ces mesures le
pour sécuriser tout le monde les enfants
les enseignants puis les parents à la
maison c mais des experts craignent que
le retour en classe crée une
augmentation des codes qu'ovide dans les
prochaines semaines il ya des personnes
qui disent c'est risqué de tourner les
enfants l'école puis je serai pas de
faire quoi que pas de risque mais c'est
un risque calculé un risque que cette
mère de famille n'est pas prête à
prendre
elle refuse pour le moment d'envoyer ses
deux enfants à l'école
les mesures actuellement à l'école sont
en moins sont trop faibles
elle croit même que le québec devrait
faire comme l'ontario il s échouent aux
parents d'un voyou pas les enfants à
l'école qui m'a dit c'est vrai ce serait
peut-être le moyen de les parrains qui
sont peau à les envoyer leurs enfants
mais qu'ils sont capables de les garder
à la maison avec d'autres parrains et le
lance une pétition pour que le
gouvernement du québec leur permettent
de garder les enfants à la maison pour
faire l'école à distance si jamais le
désir comme en ontario et si
jean-philippe robien radio canada
montréal